in addition to
burning your listings of your of your
itching throws
have you ever noticed the theme of
requirements for sacrifice
interesting question
i can't imagine why you would ask that
question are you being facetious no i
just means you must have an experience
which would cause you to ask that i've
had a lot of experiences that have
caused me to
well yes it's the question is right on
um
so
the question is has there ever been
through all of this stuff the theme of
sacrifice
and what is that
uh
very early i noticed
in dealing with the mushroom this theme
of sacrifice and i didn't it's
slightly off-putting to me
because first of all i was raised
catholic and sacrifice is a word which
vibrates but it seems to be a law of the
dao
that you cannot move forward
without
loss
and what sacrifice is
is a way of choosing
what will be lost
that's what it is
something is going to be lost
and so you can either let it all unfold
unfold and find out what's going to be
lost or you can decide to sacrifice
something and then if that sacrifice is
acceptable whatever that means no
further loss
will occur
but i had to learn this over and over
again until finally then i began
sacrificing things and then people
really thought i was nuts
because they said i said you know
i'm gonna smash my second pair of
glasses this morning
cry
i think it's a good sacrifice i think
i'd rather smash my glasses than let
this thing decide what it's going to
take with me
i said
do it
but yes this is a funny this is a funny
thing and if you don't sacrifice
then you will lose something
and it's often quite maddening so uh
it's much better to do to do the
sacrifice and i don't really understand
what this is about i've just learned
from dealing with the dao
that it it demands this uh it seems like
a purification to me
yes
although i got it to the place where i
was just pretty uh
i just understood that i had to do it i
didn't even really think about it you
know i just look around at
the objects in my life and decide what i
was willing to lose
and then lose it
and whenever i get into a situation
where i feel the neck
narrowing
then i'll sacrifice something
and then
that usually takes up the slack
[Music]
you